now in our callback we drill down to get
the get user data function this will
actually give us a pointer to the entity
that created these physics bodies that
are touching now from here we start down
a new magical rabbit hole for each of
the objects that are touching we need to
signal that a collision has occurred to
it we do this by calling a new function
called on touch and passing it in the
other physics body that it's touching so
you can see that entity a gets a
non-touch function called passing in the
body be an entity be gets a non-touch
function called passing in body a this
setup allows each individual entity to
respond to collisions in their own way
so for instance the on touch event for a
missile would remove five health from
the player it's colliding with or if
it's just hitting a wall it may just
decide to self-destruct but we haven't
written this on touch function yet and
in order to do that we need to hop all
the way back to entity jas and add an on
touch function that allows other units
to overload this function with custom
logic later it's fri worth pointing out
that you should be doing a whole series
of data checking to ensure that the
information given to the post cell
function is valid so for example whether
or not body a and body B are valid
objects or simply no and whether or not
they point to proper entity types and
have on touch functions now we'll let
you groffle through all these issues in
the future but we figured that we'd let
you get a glimpse at the madness behind
the mask so that means that anyone who
defines a physics body should also
define a non-touch function